one of the ways you can get in touch
with the show is leaving a voicemail at
two one nine two david p you can call
that number absolutely any time of day
and some of you do call very very late
but today i have a email that i want to
put up on the screen for you in a moment
i'll remind you a couple of weeks ago i
did this story about how CNBC had a
great tip a great trick for how to save
money when you go out to eat and it
turns out that the great trick was just
tip less right like just don't leave as
big of a tip and they said you know when
you look at your bill a lot of people
calculate the tip including tax so if
you have a hundred dollar bill in tax
was ten percent people tip on a hundred
and ten dollars but you don't really
need to do that you can calculate the
tip on a hundred bucks and i pointed out
that this is a just a disgusting trick
it's not even really a trick it's just
choose to tip less keep money away from
the often persistently underpaid
waitstaff of restaurants and I got a
hilarious email from Jim who is taking
it a step further Jim wrote to me and he
said hey David I saw the video on
YouTube about the CNBC trick on tipping
I figured this out years ago when I
lived in Anchorage Alaska where there is
no sales tax tax is tax and should not
be figured in on the amount to tip but I
found an even better trick many places
price their food too high if I think the
prices prices are too high on food I tip
less typically about ten percent my
thinking is that if I didn't come in the
waitstaff would be idle or less busy and
would have earned zero so my ten percent
tip is much better than earning nothing
civilization is in trouble
Jim yeah I mean it's sort of genius
right like if your opinion is that the
restaurant is too expensive just take it
out of the servers tip it's a really
cool trick that Jim has figured out I'll
remind you that once again this is one
of those situations where inequality has
exploded to such a degree corporations
and rich people have such
disproportionate power and wealth that
even though the real problem is how
they've concentrated power and run a
kleptocracy in which they decide what
are the laws what are the governing
regulations over their businesses they
are almost completely ignored and
instead you have people sort of arguing
over or fighting over does the
middle-class person whose wages are
stagnant deserve to keep a couple
percentage points of their restaurant
bill or does the persistently underpaid
waiter or waitress who is often making
263 or 283 an hour deserve to get those
couple of percentage points worth of the
tip this is by design in the same way
that the immigration debate is all about
is a Mexican person taking my job rather
than about the corporations that benefit
from cheap labor and persistently work
to take advantage of that labor once
again neat trick to save money when you
go out keep the money away for away from
underpaid servers rather than dealing
with the fact that a lot of those
servers are legally paid two dollars in
something an hour it's the wrong
conversation but it's exactly the
conversation that those in power want us
to be having we've got a great bonus
show for you today we will talk about
the leader of Isis has apparently
released his first video in five years
and there are questions about its
authenticity which we will discuss we
will also talk about you often here
don't rent an apartment you're throwing
money into the trash
buy a house or an apartment instead
there's a lot of ways in which that
advice doesn't make sense and we'll talk
about some of it on today's bonus show
and lastly a Texas lawmaker ended death
row inmates final meals the tradition of
the final meal before the state kills
you now he wants to silence the last
words of Texas death row inmates as well
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show become a member at join
pakman.com or get access by becoming a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show